des costumes de magiciens de musiciens
et même de singe charles b tout fut le
principal costumier de la comédie
française de 1919 à 1939 il a notamment
dessiné des costumes pour les
personnages des pièces de molière pour
célébrer les 400 ans de la naissance du
célèbre dramaturge certains sont exposés
exceptionnellement aux visiteurs de la
médiathèque marc ferro à saint germain
en laye ce qui m'intéressait dans cette
exposition c'était son côté voilà coloré
bien sûr molière en couleurs est
accessible à tous à la fois aux adultes
et aux enfants donc c'est le côté grand
public qui correspond bien à notre
activité ici à notre public l'exposition
regroupe au total une vingtaine de
maquettes ses dessins sont précieux pour
la minutie et l'exactitude historique
des détails est ce qu'on remarque sur
ces images
comme sur d'autres d'ailleurs c'est la
précision des détails des costumes sur
certaines maquettes les visiteurs
peuvent également retrouver des
précisions du costumier on voit sur
cette maquette les indications de du
costumier assure voilà par exemple est
bien appliquée satin bleu uni que
lingerie teinte ruban et c'est donc ce
sont des indications pour la fabrication
des costumes
l'exposition molière en couleurs est
disponible jusqu'au 29 janvier la ville
de saint germain les propose également
des spectacles et des conférences pour
fêter les 400 ans du dramaturge d'art de
la nuit de la lecture le 22 janvier les
passionnés pourront assister à des
scènes extraites des pièces de molière
au sein de la médiathèque